we want to take a quick look
I'd be federal budget the only Beach
read less appropriate than Bill Cosby's
little bill one dark and scary night and
this week Donald Trump a man who
constantly promised that he would run
America like a business gave us our
clearest sense yet of how he plans to do
that the president revealing his new
budget proposal just moments ago it is
promising the most dramatic change in
the federal government since World War
two this is a budget blueprint from the
President of the United States a
document that he puts out there it is
his wish list it is the way that he
would like the government to be funded
and and what his priorities are yes this
budget is simply a blueprint what's
known in Washington as a skinny budget
which sounds like a line item that some
might have included in one of his
prenups so try and think of it this
budget as a presidential move all the
news board of a president who's moved
can always be described an impatient
vain and horny for malice so what is in
this thing the budget blueprint calls
for a fifty four billion dollar increase
in defense spending take a look at this
graphic on the left you see a
departments getting an increase that
would be defense Homeland Security
Veterans Affairs the agencies facing
cuts the Environmental Protection Agency
the State Department the Agriculture
Department the Labor Department Health
and Human Services and the list goes on
and on you know any sort of fitting that
the list of budget cuts scroll by like
the end credits for America thanks for
helping us out Agriculture Department
help you find a gig with the next
country that rises from my ashes a well
this budget is very unlikely to pass in
its current form it is worth taking just
a few minutes to look at it partly
because it gives us a clearer sense of
our president's priorities but also
because it gives it a chance to get to
know yet another one of the Trump
administration's key characters because
we've met most of them by now so Steve
Fannin a wealthy former goldman sachs
banker who somehow constantly looks like
he just woke up on a park bench after
losing custody of his children
there is a Kellyanne Conway the brave
survivor of a terrorist attack she
completely made up
and there's Stephen Miller the least
popular boy at vampire school but for
this budget we got to know Mick Mulvaney
whose name when spoken in my accent
sounds like what you call a random Irish
person if you're trying to get in to
fight you he is the director of the
Office of Management and Budget and oh
let's I'll let him give you just a
glimpse into the highly scientific
process by which he put this budget
together we came out it actually wrote
the budget by going through the
president's speeches going through the
interviews he had given a talk to him
directly and finding out what his
priorities where we took those words
those policies and turn them into
numbers yeah basically
Mulvaney treated Trump's past statements
the way Trump treats women randomly
singling out a few of them and then
reducing them down to numbers but but
that cannot have been easy when you
think about it because translating the
noises that come out of Trump's face
into hard policy prescriptions is almost
impossible take this statement on
military spending you're going to make
the country rich again and strong again
so that you're going to forward it and
so you can afford military and all of
the other things I don't know what that
was Yonex it sounds like the audiobook
of The Farewell to Arms broadcast by an
iPhone submerged in hot coffee
but apparently Mulvaney heard increased
defense spending by fifty four billion
dollars because that is what he's
proposing and as for the budgets funding
for nuclear weapons
thank resuming we have their bases in
statements like this one
Putin has built up their military again
and again and again their military is
much stronger he's doing nuclear we're
not doing anything our nuclear is old
and tired and his nuclear is tippy-tap
from what I hear again
I don't know how you turn that into
policy
let's trickle Dickel some money bunnies
into our boom-boom budget we're aiming
for tippy-top people because remember
we're talking about the most lethal
weapons in the history of mankind so as
we can get the tippy top so that
apparently means a one point four
billion dollar increase for the National
Nuclear Security Administration while
cutting the Department of Energy's
overall budget by 1.7 billion but to be
honest I can't be certain because I
don't speak fluent toddler Psychopaths
yeah now these cuts have made headlines
for their severity but no one can say
they're surprised by who is on the
receiving end of some of the worst of
them for instance is 31% cut to the EPA
is really just making good on some
pretty clear words environmental
protection what they do is a disgrace
every week they come out with new
regulations they make it that's going to
protect the environment they will be
fine with the environment we can leave a
little bit but you can't destroy
businesses we can leave a little bit of
the environment specifically this fish
this bit of crab grass in Utah and one
of these meerkats so don't get too
attached one on the right and look there
is nothing wrong with cuts in principle
but with budget as with haircuts
it's where and how you cut that matters
and believe me I say that as a grown man
who had bangs on national television for
several years
so cool and it is important to note
non-defense discretionary spending is
already at its lowest level relative to
GDP and over 15 years lower than any
year of Reagan's presidency and that's
what makes something like trance
proposed 28% cuts to the budgets of the
State Department and USAID so
frightening
although Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson doesn't seem that worried
about it and one of the reasons he gave
for that was a little surprising what
the president is asking the State
Department to do is I think reflective
of a couple of expectations one is that
as time goes by there will be fewer
military conflicts that the US will be
directly engaged in whoa hold on that
you obviously think we're going to have
fewer military conflicts under President
Trump very simply no way that is true
he just needs one person to tell him
that World War one was called the Great
War and he's going to want to have a
better one out of sheer pettiness and
making big cuts for things like the
State Department International
Development and the EPA is just
short-sighted it took me even makes
fiscal sense the EPA is currently
responsible for 0.2 percent of federal
spending and the State Department and
USAID are 1.4 percent so you don't cut
those agencies as a cost-saving measure
you do it as a you
it is the budgetary equivalent of
inviting Mitt Romney out to dinner as
jean-georges before not offering him a
cabinet position and I will say that was
awesome by the way
close is so consistently monstrous
sometimes out of sheer coincidence he
happens to do something amazing Trump
it's really the stopped clock of
but but his pettiness extends
even further when it comes to some of
the tiny items whose budget eliminates
funding for like the National Endowment
for the Arts and the humanities and the
Corporation for Public Broadcasting
which last year made up less than point
zero two percent of federal spending
but according to Mulvaney it is unfair
to expect people to easily pave that
much when you start looking at the
places that will reduce spending one of
the questions we asked was can we really
continued
to ask a coal miner in West Virginia or
a single mom in Detroit to pay for these
programs the answer was no we can ask
them to pay for defense and we will but
we can't ask them to continue to pay for
the Corporation for Public Broadcasting
okay that argument isn't just insulting
it's absolutely ridiculous because while
yes the military keeps single mothers
safe on a day to day basis Bob the
Builder is an actual life saver for them
Declan honey mommy's gonna lie down for
a little bit while you watch yourself
some Bob he's the only man I trust
anymore and if it's your real concern is
for the hard-earned dollars of single
mothers and coal miners let's break that
down shall we
because if your single mother needs to
work and her child attends a school she
might need access to something like
wings for kids an after-school program
that serves sixteen hundred children in
three states and guess what
under President Trump's new proposed
federal budget we've primary source of
funding would be eliminated
Bridget Laird is the CEO how does that
make you feel it makes me feel
devastated Jessica Williams has two
daughters in the program what happens if
it goes away I really don't know how I
could I really don't know I will be
loved okay so that is a really bad cut
and again I say that as a man who no one
stops from going into a Supercuts with a
photo of Jenny Moore in Ghost in saying
this but worse and as for Mick Mulvaney
hypothetical coal miners let's take a
look at what Trump's budget cuts from
the Appalachian region one of those
programs at risk of losing all funding
is the Appalachian Regional Commission
which funded 35 different projects and
programs in Tennessee alone last year
certified programs in just Tennessee and
that list includes things like the
healthier Tennessee Communities
initiative the Boys & Girls Clubs of
Tennessee Valley and the governor's
books from birth foundation all of which
contains so many positive words I am
presuming that also in life 'cut are the
kids kitten hard hat aligned and the
grandmas Wish Coalition for warm cooking
straight from the oven
the cookies will be thrown away the
grandma will be put down I'm going away
by the way those cups are coming in a
state that went for trumped which leads
us to the weirdest thing of all here
some of the cuts in Trump's budget
heavily impact groups that voted for him
the one that strikes India's rural
Airport we spend money to help subsidize
real airports with it otherwise couldn't
have air service now maybe it doesn't
make any sense in an ideal world maybe
unprincipled that's a bad thing
but the people who are going to lose
their airports if we stop doing that
other people who voted for Donald Trump
so think about that Trump's rise was
fueled by people in red states who were
justifiably irritated that liberals
sometimes refer to them as flyover
country but this budget could literally
turn some of them into flyover country
because there would be no other option
and even some Republicans and our wary
of this budget how Rogers a Republican
and former chair of the House
Appropriations Committee went so far as
to call many of the cuts draconian
careless and counterproductive and the
Republican saying that about budget cuts
is like a toddler telling you this
balloon sucks
whether I really thought you liked those
and look Trump's defenders will say that
this is just him being a businessman
it's a first off they turn negotiation
the sort of thing that you could learn
all about in his book the art of the
wait I think of him betraying everyone
who supported me oh well forget it
anyway let's talk about all the trim
I've got in the 80s right fellas hunger
monger well if anything resembling this
budget passes many of trumps own voters
will likely wind up getting burned and
they are going to be angry and Trump
himself should know that given that in
the art of the deal he said this you
can't con people at least not so long
you can create excitement can do
wonderful promotion and get all kinds of
press and you can drill with a little
hyperbole but if you don't deliver the
goods people will eventually catch on oh
I think people are catching on it's
taking longer than we perhaps ideal
soon all of us will be fed up right up
to the tippy top
[Applause]